willkommen zurück ein spiel wie wahrheit
oder pflicht ohne die wahrheit
lottozahlen um zuzusehen player spielen
um geld und ruhm zu gewinnen bist du
roger oder player is the water oder
player bist du watching oder baywatch
player jojo was geht und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video und damit
zur zweiten erstellen falls es noch
nicht wisst der film läuft am 8 9 in die
kinos und ich würde sagen wir machen es
erstmal schilling gucken was wo sie auf
uns zukommt und ja viel spaß dabei ihr
alter war heute eigentlich niemand
anderes machen außer kiefer spielten
stoffe 1 0 gewonnen weil ich muss auf
jeden fall was essen weil herausgefräst
ist das bißchen hirn mal kurz mit
challandes verbringt den tag in
handschellen 500 dollar liga wollen wir
kriegen ja ja nein was meinst du auf
jeden fall anheben
da kriegen wir hin einige millisekunden
ich bisher
rösler will damit den ganzen tag verlegt
da ist halt auch ein bisschen weh das
spiel fertig machen über zwischen
allerwichtigste auf jeden fall eine
ewigkeit später als wenn ich habe
richtig hunger man also computer ganz
kurz auf toilette service dieser hatte
das nicht fordert scheringa nicht dass
sie kommen nicht nur an die tür zu gehen
ist auch mp leute wir sind jetzt hier
auch schon rettet zusammen
wir stehen ja einfach wieder
handschellen
irgendwas ist überhaupt im stehen sitzen
rissen bist du fertig die jahr
verbraucht die hand kurzen abschnitten
max muss ich jetzt abtrocknen
wenn du nicht mal die türen ja auch dann
gastiert und jetzt kommt aber los oder
ich hab echt hunger
irgendwann ist das frühstück wieder auf
meine kappe von wassertröpfchen einfach
hallo ich nehme einen buttercroissants
ja ja mit seiner legeren talent und ich
nehme so eine käse schlange bitte
entweder das geld rausholen und kriegt
das auch nicht hingehen lassen das geld
zurück los gib mir das geld essen oder
ich würde auch essen aber leute so
denken
danke
200 millisekunden später geht es um ein
pater franz was macht man eigentlich
nicht alles für 500 dollar
das andere noch irgendwas entspanntes
machen heute longboard einem lied ist 37
sekunden später dann lass mal probieren
ich bin mir nicht sicher haben wir das
hinkriegen sollen ok seitwert und heute
versichern ich völlig fertig alles und
das wird überhaupt das wird dafür mit
links drauf weg meint wir sind einfach
nur mit handschellen aneinander
gerade im rechten arm sechs stunden
später
ja
zwei stunden 4 minuten später
am anfang
also es ist so krass bei dem wetter das
zu machen er das war immer eine
verletzung da sehe ich gerade oder ein
bisschen geduldig ein rot aber mir ist
ob ich jetzt sogar mein gott was machen
wir da noch irgendwas zu anschlägen die
seite kino war echt geil einfach
reinsetzen einen langfilm über liege bei
einer harley sie wollen machen
solo wird erstmalig im film an
aber ich bin froh dass das erstmal dass
wir uns wahrscheinlich nicht zum affen
machen ihr kind waren so leute wir uns
den kinofilm angeschaut war ganz
natürlich würde ich sagen aber doch
nicht so celik ich sag nur fußfessel
fußfessel ist nicht sogar gerade auch
auf fakt alter wir müssen uns genau
aufpassen dass wir genau richtig laufen
genau den gleichen am sehnerv challenges
mache ich so fertig mittelalter ich bin
froh wenn dieser tag zu ende ist aber so
lange haben wir nicht mehr ganz spät am
abend ist es in lucka jugendlichen of
change gefahr
wir können uns an ketten beste schlüssel
liegen schlafen weiter
max alter bis dein ernst so leute das
war's vom heutigen videos fühlt sich
richtig schön an nach einem ganzen tag
in handschellen brauchen schnellstens
wieder frei zu sein
falls ihr body talk ich bin wirklich
falls ich uns im finale sehen wollt dann
checkt informationen der beschreibung
zum hashtag wette da könnt ihr nämlich
dafür sorgt dass wir beide ins finale
kommen ich frau außerdem könnte auch ihr
coole changes machen auch dazu gibt es
informationen in der beschreibung und ja
ich würde sagen du gerne den schlüssel
jetzt bitte ich brauche den schlüssel
man das tut schon weh alter das war's
von heute macht das nicht nach ist es
ziemlich ziemlich stressig und wie einen
die leute angucken
aber falls ihr noch mehr bock habt auf
nerv hier findet das nächste video von k
s und greppin und wir haben auch schon
eine challenge gemacht das finde ich auf
meinem kanal dem ich hier verlinkt und
ja ansonsten bleibt nur übrig zu sagen
habt einen schönen tag und bis auf 9